pensez de ce qui se passe à basse pointe
actuellement la tension est perceptible
à basse pointe au centre des discussions
la vague d'émissions qui secoue la
mairie quatre élus de la majorité ont
tiré leur révérence ce week end ce qui
porte à neuf le nombre d'élus
démissionnaire dans la commune
aujourd'hui on a des gens qui sont
contre une dame qui est en place et pour
cela les détruise une commune qui mérite
d'être
valoriser mois pour moi personnellement
je trouve que c'est une situation qui
est grave
booba soit il faut il faut que ça change
tout c'est le béa casimir use dit
jean-claude fait partie des quatre élus
qui ont jeté l'épongé vendredi dernier
il était pourtant le troisième adjoint
mais il ne supporte plus l'attitude du
maire qui est aussi sa soeur si moi
personnellement son grand frère
elle n'a pas pu travailler avec moi je
ne veux pas avec quelques regrets
c'est une dame et les traits
autoritaires et à abbas fait en aval
mais je savais samsung je savais que
j'étais comme ça je savais que ma soeur
était comme ça bon mais j'aime les
politiques oui quoique avec l'âge et la
lettre s'assagir pour marie thérèse
casimir yeux les démissionnaires n'ont
pas accepté de travailler pour la
population
ils n'ont pas accepté leur mission je
suis convaincu
d'une part de ça c'est l'émission m'a
apporté beaucoup plus de sérénité au
sein de l'équipe municipale par rapport
donc des orientations nous sommes fixés
je suis très attaché à la notion de
respect de l'engagement vis-à-vis de la
population parce que je rappelle que
qu'il ne s'agit pas on n'est pas au
service de quelques nouveaux biens au
service d'une population que nous devons
servir cette situation pourrait donner
lieu à des élections complémentaires
partiel pour remplacer les élus
démissionnaires et on pourrait assister
à un affrontement entre les deux camps
casini russe même si les élections total
je tiens j'ai la population d'1 semaine
de laborieuses et martiniquaise je suis
très sereine parce que la population
s'interroge aux réalisations au travail
fait elle doit savoir que moi je vais
mener campagne l'école et je vais pas
perdre même si ici on refait pas les
élections tout de suite là c'est pas
noir mais je prépare bel 20 pour 2020
et c'est si vrai javel ajouté je vais là
ajouté la valse des démissions ne serait
pas terminée à basse-pointe cette option
est aussi à l'étude chez les élus de
l'opposition
une affaire à suivre donc